[موسيقى]
مساء الخير اهلا بكم الى نشره الرابعه من
الرياض نبداوها بالعناوين
بالاعدام مرتين بحق مراهق
مشاري الانسنه في الرياضه
النشره الرابعه ترصد واقع المشاريع في
جازان مليون شجره وواجه بحريه جديده خلال
في رابعه ايضا
طقس ممطر على اغلب مناطق السعوديه جده
تتاهب لموجه جديده وتوقعات بتساقط الثلوج
في ايران افادت تقارير محليه بان الحرس
الثوريه شن حمله اعتقالات واسعه في جوان
رود بمحافظه كرمنشات ذات الاغلبيه الكرديه
مشيره الى توترا امريكي شديد وسط انتشار
واسع لقوات الحرس الثوري الايرانيه في
الشوارع
واشارت التقارير الى استخدام قوات الحرس
الايراني للغاز المثير للدموع على
المحتجين بالاضافه الى انطلاق الرصاص على
المتظاهرين ادى الى مقتل شاب يبلغ من
العمر 22 عاما
يعني دعوه تداولنا شيطون ايرانيون على
الانترنت صوره فتاه ايرانيه من منطقه
الكرديه في ايران وهي تتحدى مجموعه كبيره
من قوه الامن رافعه شعار النصر
مهدي محمد فرد بالاعدام مرتين وفق منظمتها
رارانا الحقوقيه حكم الاعدام مرتين جاء
بعد ما واجه الشاب البالغ من العمر 18
عاما تهمه الافساد في الارض بحسب المحكمه
وجرى اعتقال محمد فرد في سبتمبر الماضي
اثناء احتجاجات في مدينه نشاهد واتهامته
المحكمه انا ذاك باداره وتخطيط الاحتجاجات
وخلال مراسيم تنصيب الرئيس البرازيلي
الجديد لولاد سيلفا
ظهر فيديو سيده الاولى في البرازيل وهي
تتجنب المشاركه في استقبال الوفد
الايرانيه القادم لتهنئه الرئيس السيده
الاولى ابتعدت عند حضور ممثل ايران لتعود
الى جانب زوجها بعد رخمهم
الداخليه
وعلى صعيد اخر ذكرت هيئه البث الاسرائيليه
ان وزاره الدفاع طالبت حكومه نتنياهو
بزياده ميزانيتها بنحو عشره مليارات شيكل
اكثر من مليارين ونصف المليار دولار وقالت
مصادر امنيه اسرائيليه ان هذه الخطوات
التي تحضيره لعمل عسكري المحتمل ضد ايران
وكان وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي الجديد يوافق
جيلند اكز انه سيسعى لتامين كل
الاستعدادات المطلوبه اذا اتخذت الحكومه
قرارا بالخيار العسكري ضد دائره
هذا وافاد مراسل العربيه في القدس زياد
حلبي انه وزاره الدفاع الاسرائيليه طلبت
زياده في ميزانيتها تحسبا لاي عمل عسكريا
ضد ايران حتى وان كان لا يتعلق باي مدن
زمني واضحه واشار مراسل العربيه الى وجود
نقص في الدفائر العابره للتحصينات وطائرات
التزود بالوقود في الجيش الاسرائيلي هناك
نقص حاليا في اسرائيل
العابره للتحصينات تحديدا وطائرات تزود
وقود مشكله اسرائيل في هذا الموضوع ليس
اقتناء هذا الامر لان الصفقات تمت مع
الولايات المتحده الولايات المتحده فقط
على تزويد اسرائيل بهذه التجهيزات لكن
المشكله في الجداول الزمنيه هناك ضغط
اسرائيلي بالتقصير الجداول الزمنيه لانها
تاخذ سنوات احيانا حتى تصل هذه
من جهتها قللت الخارجيه الايرانيه من
اهميه التهديدات الاسرائيليه وقال المتحدث
باسم الخارجيه الايرانيه ناصر كنعاني
النيران لا تعيرها اهتماما وسترد بشكل
صارم على اي هجوم بحسب تعبره اما بشان
محادثات فيينا فاقد كذا كنعانيه ان ايران
لا تزال تتبادل الرسائل بشكل مستمر مع
اوروبا للوصول لنتيجه بشان الاتفاق النووي
ذلك ردنا على تصريحات وزيره الخارجيه
الالماني التي اكدت بانه لم يعد هناك
ضروره لخطه العمل الشامله المشتركه مع
ايران للجديد
رحله الانسنه في الرياض مستمره حيث انهت
امانه الرياض السنه 96 موقعا وشارعا فيما
يجري العمل حاليا على تاهيل 38 موقعا
وتتضمن اعمال الانسانيه تاهيل الارصفه
والمبرات المزيد في تقريب الزميل سالم
راجح
هنا في شوارع واحياء الرياض مظاهر الانسنه
بدات بالتزايد
مشاريعه عن سنه المدن تتضمنوا مجموعه من
العناصر لجعل المدينه صديقه للانسان من
خلال تهيئه الارصفه الجانبيه والممرات
لتكون مناسبه لممارسه رياضه المشي في
الاضافه الى تهيئه الجزر الوسطيه ومواقف
السيارات واعمال زراعه والتشجير الارقام
الرسميه مشاهدينا تشير الى اكتمال مشاريع
الانسنه في سته 96 موقعا وشارعا بالرياض
فيما يجري العمل حاليا في ثمانيه او 30
موقعا
في نطاق انسنتي الشوارع يعتبر شارع الامير
محمد بن سعد ابرز النماذج الحديثه حيث
استمر العمل فيه لمده سنه كامله قبل ان
تكتمل عناصر هذا المشروع النوعي
[موسيقى]
واجد الان الطريق الامير محمد بن سعد
انتهت اعمال السنه فيه من طريق الملك
سلمان الى طريق الامير محمد بن سلمان
بطول سته كيلو متر وكان العمل فيه على
اا على تطوير الشارع بالكامل بالكامل
الاجزاءه حرصنا على الوصوليه الشامله
وكمبليه الدستريت هندسيه نسميها اللي هو
في جزء مخصص للمشاه وجزء مخصصه لقائد
الدراجات وكذلك تنظيم المواقف وزياده
الغطاء النباتي بالطريق ولا تقتصروا اعمال
تهيئه شوارع على الطرق الرئيسيه حيث وصلت
اعمال الانسنه الى الاحياء والشوارع
الداخليه مركز وجوده الحياه يعمل من جهته
على اطلاق مجموعه من المشاريع في هذا
النطاق في عدد من المدن بالتعاون مع
الجهات البلديه وهيئات التطوير عشان نتكلم
احنا نتكلم عن تحويل المدينه الى المدينه
ملائمه للانسان او على عكس انها تكون
ملائمه للمركبه كما هو الوضع في الوقت
الحالي طبعا المشاريع اللي همم نتكلم عنها
وان شاء الله نطلقها في هذا الجانب كثيره
جزء منها تم اطلاق وجزء يعني ان شاء الله
سيطلق في العام القادم
وتاتي هذه المشاريع لدعم المستهدفات رؤيه
المملكه 20 30 تحديدا المستهدفات الرياضيه
المتمثله في تعزيز ممارسه رياضه المشي
وتقليل نسبه السمنه بين السكان بالاضافه
الى المساهمه في زياده الغطاء النباتي
العربيه الرياض
من الدمام المهندس عبد الرحمن الباحث
باحثه الدكتوره في تخطيط والتنميه المدن
دكتور مرحبا بك معي في نشره الرابعه دكتور
عبد الرحمن او مهندس عبد الرحمن عبود
خلينا نبدا معك من عدد المواقع والمشاريع
المنفذه في الرياض حتى الان يعني 96 مشروع
او موقع تقريبا في ست سنوات
2016 تقريبا
ما شاء الله همم
محمد بن سلمان
انه اصلا الهدف الاساسي انشاء المدينه ايش
الابتكار المدينه هذا كان هدف الاساسي منه
حمايه الانسان حمايه الانسان فقط
مش عندي مكافه اشكال التلوث فهو هذا الهدف
الاساسي
المدينه
والتنميه الحضاريه لكن مع خلينا نقول توسع
المدن همم بالتطور الحضري الهائل بدا يعني
الانسان يشعر بانه يعني ضئيل ومسلوب
التامل في هذه المدينه ولا يتشعر ان
المدينه يعني تحتويه همم مرافقها وفرغاتها
ورحلته اليوميه فاصبح يعني هناك فجوه همم
كبيره ومن هنا يعني بادرك همم كثير من
قاده من او بعد قاده المدن هذه الفجر ومن
ابرزهم يعني نذكر الدكتور عبد العزيز
الرياض السابق اطلق يعني حزمه من البرامج
مثلا مشاريع الانسنه في مدينه الرياض ولا
زالتمر او ايضا يعني تداول هذا المصطلح
هذا المفهوم في كافه المناطق المملكه
ممتازه احنا بنشوفه بصراحه نموذج جميل جدا
على ارض الواقع من خلال شارع الامير محمد
بن سعد
زميل رساله من الراجل همم لكن الى اي مدى
او ما هي المعايير المطبقه على الشوارع او
السؤال بشكل اخر هل كل الشوارع يمكن ان
تقبل او ان تنفذ فيها مثل هذه المشاريع
ولا لا معايير محدده يعني
رائع جدا
تختلف على حسب حجم المدينه
لكن ممكن نقول بشكل عام يعني
المعايير الكبرى الاساسيه في السنه المدن
خلينا نقول له الحمايه حمايه الانسان في
رحله اليوميه وتنقلاتها في استخدامات
اليوميه من كافه اشكال التلوث وايضا
الراحه يشعر بالراحه اذا هو ليس فقط
المحميه من مخاطر سرعه السيارات وغيرها
لكن يشعر بالراحه والمعيار الثالث يستمتع
في هذه الرحله في هذا الدفاع هذه هذه
يتحققت نقدر نقول ان هذا الطريقه وهذا
الحي يعني اكثر صديق اكثر قابليه للمشي
اكثر همم زياده درجه الحراره المدينه صارت
تؤثر الايجابه على الانسان وترفع من
معنوياته ويشعر انه يعني محترفه في هذه
القناه اليوميه وبالتالي
نسبه يمكن القول بانه البنيه التحت في في
شوارع يعني مثلا في الرياض
كمثال يعني هي مناسبه
لهذه المشاريع المشاريع الانسجه
همم بالتاكيد طبعا المدينه مثل الرياض
يعني صعبه وتحدي فيها كبير جدا انها تصير
صديقه للانسان ومثلا خلينا نقول
تقلل من هجمه السياره الخاصه بشكل كبير
لكن بشكل تدريجي ممكن نصل الى هذه المرحله
من خلال يعني مجموعه من المشاريع النوعيه
التي تتكامل مع بعضها اللي ممكن تتحقق
على مستوى المدينه لكن ممكن الان نبدا
بالتحقيق مستوى انثى على بعض الاحياء على
بعض الشوارع الحركه البسيطه من همم محيط
المنزل ثم تنتقل بشكل تدريجي على كافه
المراحل مش انعكاسات
نكسات جدا ايجابيه ورائعه يعني ممكن
تحسب من جوزه الحياه انت اصلا الى المدينه
الان اصبحت يعني معزوله اصبحنا في شبه
صناديق مهزوله عن ااا انتقام بالناس
معزوله عن التواصل معزوله عن اي شعور
ايجابي ممكن تحقق لك المدينه فالمدينه
الان يعني اصبحت عيب على الانسان
يعاني من كثير من مصادر التلوث همم الروح
حق الانسان صارت شويه همم
كئيبه من كثر يعني همم الحفاظ الرقعه
الخضراء انخفاض مساحه المشي اصبحت السياره
يعني تسبب خطر على الانسان فمشاريع
الانسان لها يعني همم تنعكس بشكل ايجابي
هذا خلينا نقول على الانسان المكتمل
السليم الصحيح لكن في الانسان يمر بمراحل
عديده من هذه مثلا همم المعاق منها الطفل
من هيك كبير السن المراه هذا جميع مراحل
الانسان مثل المدينه اللي تحتوي بشكل كبير
زي كلها اثر ايجابي على هذه المدينه ويحقق
يعني نموها وتفاعلها معه ويكون ايجاب بشكل
اكبر من من ما كان مثلا عدو له او غير
صديقه همم لها بشكل كبير طيب هذه من
الجوانب لكن ممكن متابع يقول كذلك احنا
لما نشوف هذا الشارع بدات يمكن وغيره
كذلك يمكن يكون له سلبيات ايضا يعني هي
فكره الانسه لا تقوم على
الارصفه الجانبيه همم ممرات للمشاه ممرات
للدراجات وغيرها يعني تقريبا هي اللي
شفناه انه في شارع تجاري ممر للسيارات
ماخذ 10 متر تقريبا
الرصيف ما قد 20 متر تعرف انه احنا عندنا
مشكله الان في ازدحام واقتناق كذلك مرورك
كثير وكانوا امس يعني المرور عاملين
اجتماع بهذا الخصوص واتكلموا عن 16 مليون
رحله يوميا يعني فبالتالي ادي 1 كان لها
ايجابيات من ناحيه الا انها ممكن ان تسبب
ايضا زياده في حالات الاختناق المروريه
بالرقم الكبير المعلم اليوم كيف تنظر لها
صحيح لذلك هو التعامل يعني لا بد ان يكون
حساس جدا ويكون كنت تدريجي لكن
خلينا نقول في نطاق الحي
الاحجام المروريه يعني اقل من ما بتكون
مثلا في الطرق السريعه فااه مثل هذه
المعايير اكيد اي تغيير يعني تعود عليه
الناس ممكن يواجه يعني خلينا نقول معارضه
انه كيف كان ضيقته الطريق صار الطريق همم
الى اخره لكن ما يعني خلينا نقول التعود
وتجربه هذه يعني همم طريقه
الناس بمعنى انه يوقف سيارته ممكن ياخذ
الطريق هذا بيمشي فيه بدل من انه يستخدم
سيارته في هذا الطريقه
احسنت بالضبط صحيح ان اشير هنا نقطه مهمه
يعني كل ما كان مشاريع الانسنه بمشاركه
الناس والجلوس معهم واخذ مرئياتهم كلما
كان يقابليتهم لي هذا التغيير الحضري اكثر
يعني قبولا واكثر تقبلا لو كان باتجاه
واحد من خلال البلديه او خلال العمل شكرا
جزيلا لك من الدمام المهندس عبد الرحمن
الدكتوراه في التخطيط والتنميه
قصده اكثر من 2500 تعدي هنا على خدمات
الكهرباء والمياه الخاصه بالمساجد في بعض
المدن السعوديه
بين القوات الجويه السعوديه وسلاح الجو
البريطاني في قاعده الملك فهد الجويه
في العمليات القتاليه وتبادل الخبرات
العسكريه في مجال العمليات الجويه ورفع
مستوى الجاهزيه القتاليه للبلدين
اكثر من مليون شجره زرعت في منطقه جازان
خلال الاشهر الماضيه ضمن مبادره السعوديه
الخضراء في ما تم استحداثه واجهات بحريه
بمساحه 350 الف متر مربع
ستربط الكورنيش بضاحيه الملك عبد الله
التي تحوي 40 الف قطعه سكنيه فضلا عن
معالجه التشوهات البصريه في المدينه
اسامه يعني ضعنا في تفاصيل هذه المشروعات
في منطقه جازان
اهلا وسهلا خالي تحيه طيبه لك ولجميع
مشاهدي قناه العربيه نتحدث اليوم بالتاكيد
من هنا من منطقه جازان وبالتحديد من امام
مواجهتها البحريه عدد المشاريع التي نفذت
اليوم في امانه جازان وايضا المشاريع
المستقبليه كبيره جدا تفوق العشرين مشروعا
منها ان سنه الطرق وايضا تحسين المشهد
الحضري تتحدث اليوم ايضا خالد عن عدد كبير
جدا من البرامج التي قامت بها الامانه وفي
خبر الحصري للعربيه امام الجازان تستهدف
انشاء ممشى يعتبر اطول المماشي الذي
يتجاوز طوله 25 كم مربع والذي يضبط
الواجهات البحريه في بعضها البعض وجهها
جازان البحريه اليوم سبع واجهات كاكثر
منطقه في السعوديه اترككم الان في جوله
ايضا حول المشاريع التي تم تنفيدها هنا في
امانه منطقه جازان ايضا امانه جازان
تستهدف خلال شتاء جازان زراعه اكثر من
300,000 زهره ضمن
انجازات حدث اليوم ايضا خالد عن هذه
المشاريع النوعيه كون ان منطقه جازان ايضا
اصبحت منطقه جاذبه استثمارين خصوصا بعد
الاتفاقيات الصينيه السعوديه كل هذه
البرامج واكثر تعطي ايحاء جديده ووجهه
جديده بان جازان اصبحت منطقه واعده بكل
تاكيد هذه المشاريع واكثر التي نفذتها
امانه منطقه جازان من خلال ايضا تكثيف
الغطاء النباتي الحديث اكثر عن هذه
المشاريع يسعدون ان يكون معي الان الامين
امين منطقه جازان المهندس يحيى غزواني
للحديث اكثر عن هذه المشاريع اهلا وسهلا
فيك مهندس ابتداءا معنا اليوم في نشره
الرابعه حدثني اليوم عن ما هي المشاريع
التي قمتم بها في امانه جازان في تحسين
المشهد الحضري
مساء الخير يا اسامه لك وليد زملائك في
الاستديو سعيد بتواجد معكم في قناه
العربيه وميسي على مشاهديكم خلف الشاشات
ااا في البدايه تقدم
بجزيره الشكر والتقدير لصاحب السوري
الملكي امير المنطقه وسمو نائبه ولمعالي
وزير الشؤون البلديه والكرويه على ما نجده
في امانه منطقه جازان من دعم همم كبير جدا
وشكر موصول لزملائي رائعين في الامانه
والبلديات المرتبطه يعتبر تحسين المشهد
الحضري احد اهم البرامج التي تعمل عليها
الامانه لرفع مستوى اا جوده الحياه في
منطقه جاذبه سياحيه واقتصاديا كما منطقه
جازان خلال فتره الماضيه ركزنا على معالجه
شوهه البصريه ولازلنا نعمل همم عليها ضمن
خطه وطنيه موحده همم استحدثنا شاطئ جديد
همم شمال موقعنا الحالي بمساحه تقارب
350,000 متر اوبا يعتبر امتداد الواجهه
البحريه همم
الشماليه عملنا على زياده نصيب همم الفرد
من الساحات والمسطحات الخضراء وتتجاوزنا
مستهدفات العام 20 22 بنسبه 135% اذا
مهندس تعني اسالك ايضا سؤال اخر منطقه
جازان جبليه ساحليه بحريه بالتاكد انه هذا
يعطي تنوع كبير جدا على المستوى السياحي
ما هي الرؤيه المستقبليه اليوم لامانه
جازان في هذا التنوع نعمل حقيقه في همم
الفتره القادمه على مشاريع النوعيه اهمها
ربط الكورنيش الشمالي بضاحيه الملك عبد
الله طبعا الضاحيه هي مخطط نموذج نادر على
مستوى المملكه [__] 40,000 قطعه سكنيه
وشاطر بطول 16 كيلو همم يرتبط بمطار الملك
عبد الله ايضا نعمل على همم التوسع في
الملاعب والماشي وحاليا نعمل على ممشى
الواجهه الذي شرط بالهي في مقدمتكم وهو
يعتبر من اطول المماشي نعمل ايضا على
تطوير وانسنت العشوائيات ولتو رجعنا من
جوله مع سمو امير المنطقه للعشوائيات جنوب
همم همم المدينه وخلال الفتره القادمه ان
شاء الله سنعمل على عشوائيات همم
العشوايات في العشيمه همم نستهدف في
الفتره همم القادمه مشاركه القطاع الخاص
همم في تطوير همم البنيه التحتيه وانشاء
مشاريع ترفيهيه نوعيه وهمم واسامه استغل
همم منبركم هنا لدعوه كبار رجال الاعمال
والمستثمرين على التوجه الى منطقه جازان
وسنقوم بتقديم كل ما يلزم من همم دعمه
وتسهيل الامور ان شاء الله
المهندس يحي غزواني وانت امين منطقه جازان
شكرا لك اذا اتحدث اليوم ايضا خالد عن
شتاء جازان وهو عرس جيزان الست السنوي
الذي سوف يحكم بحول الله تعالى في مطرح
هذا الشهر تحديدا في الثاني عشر من يناير
يعني يقول ايضا خاتمه خالد وانا في هذه
المنطقه في اجواء جازان الساحره ان رحله
البحث عن السعاده والترفيه والجمال تنتهي
هناك
تقريبا من 23 الى 28 في هذا التوتل
المهرجان
وان شاء الله
مباشره الان الى ملعب سانتوس البرازيلي
حيث توضع الان او يوضع جثمان الاسطوره
البرازيلي
تمهيدا لمراسم التشريعه ثم الدفن
نشاهد الان الجماهير ربما تنظر النظره
الاخيره
لمتابعه الان
الجثمان
ومراسم همم التشيع قبل دفنه
رصدت وزاره الشؤون الاسلاميه اكثر من 2500
تعديا على خدمات الكهرباء والمياه في
المساجد حيث كان
2390 تعديل منها على خدمات الكهرباء
136 على خدمات المياه الخاصه في المساجد
والجوائر
اسلاك الكهرباء وانابيب المياه والتوصيلها
الى ممتلكاتهم الخاصه ما دفع اداره حمايه
مرافق المساجد بالتعاون مع الوزاره الى
رصد التعديات الاحاله
اصبح الاعتماد على المحافظ الرقميه في
السعوديه الشائعا مع تزايد حلول الدفع
الالكترونيه التي تقدمها شركات المدفوعات
العامله في المملكه والتي يبلغ عددها 23
شركه حتى الان
اقبال متزايد على استخدام المحافظ الرقميه
في السعوديه مع التسهيلات التي قدمتها تلك
المحافظ في عمليات تحويل الاموال المحلي
والدولي ودفع رواتب العماله وشراء التذاكر
والسلع من المتاجر والمواقع الالكترونيه
بسيطه
حول المجموعات اضافه الاموال فيها دون
الحاجه لبيانات بنكيه وتسهل حساب القيمه
المطلوبه من كل فرد يعني بالنسبه لي انا
الاعتمادي عليها اسهل عن طريق الجوال ممكن
اطلع الجوال احاسيس فيها اي مكان
بعض الاحيان احنا والشباب في الاستراحه
قطاعه شيء بدل مع كاش صار شيء لا يعني
محوله رضينا اكثر شيء صراحه استخدمها اللي
يقطه الشباب يعني بالاول خذ الايبان واكد
الرقم واخذ رقم الحساب وصل ما وصل الحين
خلاص ابحث اشوف الاسم وعلى طول حول بعدين
احوي اربعه اعوام من اطلاق محفظتي اس تي
سي بي بلغت عمليات التحميل لتطبيقها على
الهواتف الذكيه اكثر من واحد و20 مليون
عمليه تحميل الامر الذي يشير الى التطورات
المتتابعه في اسلوب التعاملات الماليه في
البلاد
من الرياض نواف عزيز العربيه
رابع مستمره فيها بعد قليل
المخاوف من كربونات تتجدد قطر تفرض قيود
على المسافرين القادمين من الصين
مشاريع الانساني تتواصل في الرياض
والانتهاء من تاهيل الارصفه والممرات في
96 موقعا
ترصد واقع المشاريع في جازان مليون شجره
وواجه بحريه جديده خلال 20022
رقص ممطر على اغلب مناطق السعوديه جد جده
تتاهب لموجه جديده
والتوقعات بتساقط الثلوج على نيوم
اهلا بكم امطار المتفاوته الغزاله تشهدها
مناطق عده في السعوديه شملت اخر التحذيرات
استماره موجه الامطار الغزيره على منطقه
مكه المكرمه اضافه الى توقعات بتساقط
البرد على الطائف ومكه وليف مشاهده مدينه
جده امس الاحد هطول امطار متوسطه الى
غزيره واعلم تجاره التعليم في جده تعليق
الدراسه ليوم الغد العاصمه الرياض ايضا
شهيده اليوم بطوله امطار خفيفه الى متوسطه
مع توقعات الاستمرارها كما كشف المركز
الوطني للارصاد ايضا عن احتماليه تساقط
الثلوج على مرتفعات منطقه تبوك ومنها على
جان الظهر وجبل اللوز والاطراف
كما تتابع محطه مرصد مطار الملك عبد
العزيز الدولي في جده تابعه للمركز الوطني
للارصاد حاله الطقس على مدار الساعه عبر
الاجهزه والتقنيات الحديثه لمتابعه الحاله
الجويه وعناصر الطقس تتكون من اثنتي عشره
محطه رصد اوتوماتيكيه موزعه في مدينه جده
تتبعوا المركز الوطني للارصاد وتعاملوا
على اصدار القراءات وكميات الامطار بشكل
ذكي ودون تدخل البشري
نتابع مع مراسله العربيه سلطان سليمان من
جده وعبد الواحد الحميد من الرياض اجواء
عبد الرحمن عبد الواحد وكذلك سلطان لكن
ربما كميه الامطار في جده اكثر اكثر غزاره
ااا ولكن كما نشاهد في الصوره ربما اقل من
ما نشاهده في الرياض الان
كيف جده وكيف الامطار في هلا
اهلا اهلا
ظهر اليوم وتحديدا في تمام الساعه الواحده
وحتى الساعه الثانيه
ظهر اليوم امطار من متوسطه الى خفيفه في
انحاء مختلفه من جده وتركزت في شمال وشرق
وجنوب المحافظه سجلت منسوب المياه في او
كميات المياه في معظم هذه المناطق الثلاث
شمالا وشرقا وجنوبا الى اربعه مللي متر
وانتهت الحاله كذلك من المتوقع ان تستمر
الحاله خلال الساعات القادمه وحتى غدا في
تمام الساعه الحاديه 10 مساء وكذلك من
المتوقع خلال الاسبوع القادم ان تكون
هنالك حاله جديده نتواجد حاليا في محطه
الرصد داخل مطار الملك عبد العزيز الدولي
بجده وهي المحطه
الماهوله التابعه لمركز الوطني للارصاد
اتحدث عن هذه المحطه التي تتشكل من حديقه
اراست عباره عن مكان مخصص عبر يتشكل في او
يتشكل من اجهزه رصد حديثه لقياس درجات
الحراره وكذلك كميات مياه الامطار وايضا
الرطوبه وكذلك درجه الحراره ايضا نتحدث
على همم مبنى مهيا من 25 موظف يعملون على
مدار الساعه لاصدار النشرات والتقارير
الانيه واللحظيه وكذلك تركز هذه المحطه
بشكل كبير على خدمه الملاحه الجويه هنا في
مطار الملك عبد العزيز الدولي بجده وكذلك
تزويد المركز الرئيسي للارصاد بالتقارير
على مدار الساعه نتحدث في جده بشكل عام
هنالك 12 محطه اوتوماتيكيه بمختلفا انحاء
محافظه جده تعمل على اصدار القراءات
وكميات مياه الامطار بشكل ذكي وطبعا بدون
تدخل يتحدث في السعوديه بشكل عام هنالك 28
محطه
جوي تتحدث عن هذه المحطه التي يعمل بها
تعمل بها الكوادر السعوديه عبر الاجهزه
وتقنيات حديثه هنالك مهام او ثلاث اقسام
رئيسيه بمقدمتها قسم الت واتور قسم الرصد
الجوي وقسم رصد طبقات الجو العليا من خلال
يعني همم
فتح بالون يتم اطلاقه في السماء يصل
الارتفاع الى ثلاثه وهمم 33,000 متر
ارتفاعا نتحدث انه قسم التنبؤات هنا في
هذا المركز يعمل على رصد او عفوا الستاره
التحذيرات بمختلف مستوياتها والتوقعات
الانيه والاحذيه للجو في ما يتعلق بقسم
الرصد الجوي يعمل على ستار النشرات على
الساعيه وعلى وكذلك نشرات الروتينيه
اليوميه لخدمه الملاحه الجويه وكذلك عامل
نشرات الخاصه فيما يتعلق بتدهور وتحسن
الطقس في ما يتعلق بمحطه البالون يتم رصد
طبقات الجو العليا من خلال يعني عناصر
الطقس من سطح من سطح الارض الى اعلى ويصل
ارتفاع كما ذكرني الى 33,000 متر هو اليوم
هنا في محطه الرصد وكذلك محطه الرصد
توماتيكيه في جده يتم رصد حاله الجو على
مدار الساعه وتزويد الجهات المعنيه بمختلف
القطاعات الحكوميه الخاصه على راس كل ساعه
التعامل مع الحالات الجويه نعم الى حد ما
في جده مش زي الاجواء البارده يعني الان
في الرياض مع الامطار كذلك عبد الواحد
الصوره من عندك كيف تصل
نعم خالد طبعا كما تعلم الامطار بدات
تقريبا منذ الخامسه فجرا ولم تتوقف حتى
الان الا انها يعني تتوقف بشكل جزئي وتعود
مره اخرى يعني همم تحديدا نحن نقف الان في
همم طريق الملك فهد وان نشاهد حركه السير
السادس بعض الشيء الامطار ليست كثيره انما
متوسط في مختلف انحاء العاصمه الرياض همم
ربما اثرت بشكل جزئي على بعض الفعاليات
والمناسبات يعني هيئه الترفيه اعلنت عن
همم الاغلاق بشكل مؤقته انترلاد وقريه
زمان اضافه الى ان الجهات الرسميه نتحدث
عن امانه الرياض كانت همم يعني همم اكدت
ونبهت المواطنين والمقيمين على همم ضروره
الابتعاد عن مناطق همم السيول في عدد من
التنبيهات التي اصدرتها امانه الرياض
نتحدث همم
يعني تنبيه الامانه للبقاء في المنازل
فيما لو كانت هناك امطار غزيره اضافه الى
طبعا الابتعاد عن همم قطع مياه الامطار
والسيول بالسيارات همم خالد كما تعلم
الحاله المطريه مستمره في العاصمه الرياضي
اضافه الى
المناطق والمحافظات والمراكز التابعه
لمنطقه الرياض اا نتحدث عن الزلفي
والمزاحميه وغيرها من المناطق التابعه
التي تشهد امطار همم متوسطه الى غزيره
يعني منذ ساعات صباح الاولى نسبه الرطوبه
خالد كما اعلن المركز الوطني للارصاد
تجاوزت 95% في العاصمه الرياض اضافه الى
همم التوقعات التي اشار اليها المركز في
في اعلانه همم ان الامطار ربما ستستمر حتى
يوم الاربعاء هذه هي ابرز التفاصيل خالد
وفيما يتعلق في حاله المطريه همم في
الرياض اليوم
توقفت
متوقع ان تستقطب يعني
الكثير من الناس لكن في فاعليه واحده
ضمنها راح تجذب جماهير كبيره اليوم الدون
بيوصل كريستيانو رونالدو للريال
او بكره جماهير النصر اكيد يعني ما راح
يمنعها لما اضطر ولا غيره في استقباله ولا
لا يا عبد الله
يعني اكيد مع المطر وصول كريستيانو
العاصمه الرياض مختلفه
طيب شكرا جزيلا لكم
في الموضوع انه زعلان من القصه قصه
رونالدو وجايته
شكرا لكم
ذكرت وكاله الانباء القطريه الرسميه ان
قطر ستطلب من جميع المسافرين القادمين من
الصين اعتبارا من غدا الثلاثاء تقديم
نتيجه سلبيه الاختبار كرونا في غضون 48
ساعه من المغادره واضافه الوكاله بين
الشرطه الاختبار المفروض على جميع
المسافرين بغض النظر عن التطعيم فيما لم
تعلن الدول الخليجيه الاخرى عن اي قيود
على المسافرين القادمين من الصين
في محافظه رفحاء في منطقه الحدود الشماليه
السعوديه حول المواطن على الخرفان جزء من
منزله الى متحف خاص يحتوي على العديد من
المقتنيات التراثيه التي جمعها على مدار
[موسيقى]
وخصص جزءا من منزله كمتحف مفتوح يستقبل
الزوار والمهتمين
[موسيقى]
بدينا بل المتحف من عام 1407 جماعه من
التراث القديم ما يقارب 1000 قطعه منها
الاسلحه بانواعه الفتيل الصبعيه المارتين
اعماره فوق 200 عام عندك تغتصب الابل شداد
النطع الخرج عندنا القطعه هذه تسمى
الزناد عمره اكثر من 300 عام
قديمه قديمه
بالحفلات والمناسبات والاعياد
وتصنع صناعه يدوي من الصوف الخالص الخرفان
الذي استهوى جمع نحوي الف قطعه من التراث
يستقبل زواره بشكل يومي بالقهوه السعوديه
في مجلس زينه بالعديد من الادوات التراثيه
انا من زوار مجلس ابو حسين وما شاء الله
ما هو مجلس صار تراثي وصار متحف حقيقه
ونشكره على
المغنيات الحلوه هذه التقنيات الحلوه هذه
وتراثيه والحمد لله هذا يجونها الطلاب
الصغار ويشوفون طال عمرك ترى اباهم
وجدادهم هذا المتحف الخاص الذي يحاكي
تاريخ المنطقه قديما بمقتنياته التراثيه
يسال خرفان الى تطويره بمزيد من القطاع
النادره من محافظه رفحاء جزاء العربيه
[موسيقى]
اخبار الرياضه الان مع زياد عبيدات
شكرا يا خالد واهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام
يصل الليله اللاعب البرتغالي كريستيانو
رونالدو الى العاصمه السعوديه الرياض
قديما من العاصمه الاسبانيه مدريد تمهيدا
للاعب مع نادي النصر السعودي وينتظر ان
يقدم النادي لاعبه الجديد الى الجماهير
غدا الثلاثاء في ملعب مرسول بارك في
العاصمه السعوديه وسطها حضور جماهرين
واعلاميين كبير من داخل السعوديه وخارجها
وبحسب صحيفه الرياضيه المتخصصه سالقي
كريستيانو خلال الحفل كلمه قصيره يخاطب
فيها جماهير نادي الجديد
وصل نعشوا على اسطوره البرازيلي فيليه الى
ملعب نادي سانتوس حيث سيبدا النادي الذي
لعب له الراحل معظم مسيرته مراسم التشييع
في الملعب اليوم الاثنين وستقوم الجماهير
بالقائه النظره الاخيره على بليه لمده 24
ساعه وبعد انتهاء مراسم القاء النظره
الاخيره سيمر موكب الجنازه عبر شوارع
سانتوس
انطلقت اليوم المرحله الثانيه مره ذكر
المقام حاليا في السعوديه للعام الرابع
على التوالي مسافه المرحله الثانيه وصلت
الى 589 كيلو متر وبدات من ينبع الى العلا
ونجح المتسابق مثلا كلاين بخطف في صداره
فئه الدراجات من الامريكيه
وكان المتسابق الاسباني السيارات
[موسيقى]
البكار الحقيقه من اهم الفعاليات اللي
احنا نقيمها في المملكه العربيه السعوديه
زي ما انتم الان شاهدتم بانفسكم كيف كفر
العدد المشاركين كل هالابطال وكلها الفرق
من انحاء العالم تيجي عشان تحاول انها
تنافس وتثبت نفسها على ارض المملكه
العربيه السعوديه بانها قادره ان تخوض
اصعب الراليات واكبر الراليات وامهم على
الاطلاق وهو رالي دكار همم السعوديه اسماء
اكبر اسماء موجوده اهم الاسماء في عالم
الرياضيات موجوده في ارض حقيقه يعني تعطيل
كثير للراليات شاهدنا اا خلال الاربع سنين
الماضيه همم
مناطق جدا جميله مناطق جدا همم همم يعني
همم
مخصصه للراليات في التنوع الجغرافي ما
تلقى في اي بلد ولا اي مكان الا الحمد لله
بلد مثل المملكه العربيه السعوديه
ولا تاخذ يعني كلامي انا اسال متسابقين
كيف يشوفوا المنافسه كيف شافه الحمد لله
الترتيبات التجهيزات اللي يقدمها المملكه
العربيه السعوديه في جميع همم
المناسبات فهي بشهاده الجميع لله الحمد
افضل نسخ دكار على الاطلاق
في المملكه العربيه السعوديه نشوف السنه
هذه انتقلنا في مناطق جديده همم كانت
البدايه من ينبع والنهايه هتكون في في
المنطقه الشرقيه
في انطلاقه الجولان 11 من الدوري المصري
لكره القدم يلتقي الليله النادي الاهلي مع
ضيفه بيراميدز على استاد القاهره الدولي
ويحتل الاهلي المركز الثاني ب 24 نقطه
ويسعى الى مصالحه جماهيره بعد التعادل في
اخر مبارتين بينما يحتل بيراميدز المركز
الرابع برصيد 20 نقطه الموسم الماضي التقى
الفريقان ثلاث مرات حيث تغلب الاهلي في
ذهاب بمسابقه الدوري وخسر ايابا ونجح
الاهلي بالفوز على منافسه في الدور ربع
النهائي لمسابقه كاس مصر في كره القدم
كبيره جدا جدا لعبد القادر وطول
الحساب الجوله التاسعه 10 من الدوري
الانجليزي الممتاز لكره القدم يستقبل برنت
فورد الليله نادي ليفربول الذي سيدخل هذه
المباراه بمعنويات عاليه خاصه بعد الفوز
على ليستر سيتي بهدفين بهدف واحد في
الجوله الماضيه ويملك فريق المدرب يورجن
كلوب 28 نقطه مقابله 23 نقطه لفريقه برنت
فورد
وتعرض توتنا من الخساره امامها بهدفين دون
مقابل ضمن منافسات الاسبوع الثامن عشر من
الدوري الانجليزي الممتاز لكره القدم بهذه
النتيجه رصيده الى احدى 20 نقطه فيما تجمد
رصيد وتوتنهام عند 30 نقطه
شهدت الجوله العاشره من الدوري الاسترالي
لكره القدم فوزه اديلاي دونايتد على بيرث
جلوري بهدفين مقابل لا شيء اول اهداف لقاء
كان في الدقيقه ال 40 من زمن اللقاء واضاف
هالوران الهدف الثاني في الدقيقه 72 بهذه
النتيجه ارتفع رصيد ادي لايت الى 15 نقطه
وتجمد رصيده جلوري عند نقاط
[تصفيق]
ونجح فريقه من البورنو سيتي بالفوز على
لينكتون بثلاثه اهداف مقابل هدف واحد في
الدوري الاستراليه
الهدف الاول لفريقي وليكن في الدقيقه
الثالثه عشر قبل ان يعادل المافيولاك
النتيجه لمصلحته من البورن سيتي بعدها
بدقيقتين ومن ركله جزاء اضافه
التقدم لفريق في الدقيقه الحاديه والخمسين
واعداء نفسه واحرز ثاني اهدافه وثالثه
لفريقه الذي رفع رصيده الى اثنتين و20
نقطه من 90 مباريات في صداره الدوري
الاسترالي لكره القدم
نهايه اخبار الرياضه شكرا لكم على حسن
المتابعه وعوده اليك خالد
[موسيقى]
ونعود لمتابعه هذه الصور المباشره من ملعب
سانتوس في البرازيل حيث النظره الاخيره
التي تلقى على جثمان الاسطوره البرازيلي
بلاد تمهيدا لمراسم التشهد
نجم الكره الاسطوري اختيار مقبره خارجه عن
المالوف ليدفن فيها تحديدا في الطابق
التاسع من مبنى فخم يطل على ملعب سانتوس
حيث تالق وحضيه باكبر نجاحات في عالم كره
القدم
اليوم التاسع من الشهر الهجري سيقترب
القمر مع الثريا وهو دلال على شده البرد
خالد
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اجمل ما بالكون الثريا كان الثريا هودج
فوق ناقه يسير بها حاد من الليل مزعجه وقد
لمعت بين النجوم كانها قوارير فيها زئبق
يترجى رجل واجمل ما بالكون القمر واذا
اجتمع الجمالين الجمال الكوني مع جمال
النجوم الثريا في اليوم التاسع من الشهر
الهجري قال العامه القمر قارن ثريا وهذا
يدل على شده البرد وقالوا جراند تاسع بردن
[تصفيق]
مرور القمر بيننا وبين الشمس يسمى كسوف
ومرور القمر بيننا وبين نجمه او كوكب يسمى
احتجاب ومرور القمر بجانب نجمه او كوكب
يسمى اقتران ففي يوم الاثنين يبي يوما
القمر بجنبه ريا وفي يوم الثلاثاء سيحجب
القمر كوكب المريخ وهذا يدل على ان القمر
اقرب الينا من الكواكب ومن النجوم ومن
الشمس ان تلقوا مرو والشمس والارض والكون
وانت السماء وانت النجوم
الرفيع
[موسيقى]
اذكروا بالعناوين
الاحتجاجات في ايران لا تتوقف اعتقالتهم
في كرمنشاه وحكم بالاعدام مرتين بحق
المراه
في الرياضه التواصل الانتهاء من تاهيل
الارصفه والممرات في 96 موقع
الرابعه ترصد واقع المشاريع في جازان
مليون شجره وواجه بحريه جديده خلال 2022
وتقص ممطر على اغلب المناطق السعوديه جده
تتاهب لموجه جديده وتوقعات بالتساقط
الثلوج على نيوم
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]